Sam we were watching you on camera as
this game was unfolding and you seemed
distressed uh yeah well that was the
reason well so first of all they didn't
even ask me to come for an interview I
came because I requested I just wanted
to say I'm I'm sorry for how this ended
uh I've been one of the most vocal
critics of people making this Queenie
for Queen D4 draw on the Berlin I wrote
in my trustable course to anyone who
does this more than once with white just
shouldn't be invited to tournaments like
and so
uh it just feels like I just felt like
oh the world an apology I know I'm
playing Black and there's not much I can
do but I remember I really wanted to win
this game I mean I played the night off
and
um
was ready to take a lot of risks but I
remember preparing like it just I had
never once ever seen Dominguez Force so
draw with white like literally zero
times it's just such a principle
aggressive strong player who really
tries to fight for an edge I just hadn't
occurred to me at all and I just found
myself wishing I had found some way to
just like play E5 and go but I just
hadn't checked it in the slightest and
having tried to win with black several
times this tournaments when it was
probably inappropriate I like for
example against Jeffrey when I could
have just traded all the pieces and I
played Bishop D5 and gave myself an
isolated Pawn instead I just sort of
decided to make the adult decision but
it was not one that I'm proud of or not
one that I think that we should use as
an example for chess players in the
future and I assume you're talking about
your game against Levon aronian where
you had white people that one was a
little different and that I just got
caught in preparation and some extremely
obscure line uh that just I mean that
can happen and then that's that's that
but that's that's very different than a
draw happening that's probably been
played a thousand times in the past uh
and when that happens I don't really
think you can blame the black player but
still I don't like how it went down Sam
uh you finished on plus one how would
you assess your performance do you feel
you could have done differently it was
mediocre
um not terrible like I've probably lost
a little bit of writing despite having
an extra white I mean I remember I've
had an extra black and something like 10
of my last 10 events and so when I got
an extra light at this tournament I just
felt like a kid at Christmas and I was
really looking forward to trying to do
something and I just I mean
there's basically I finished on plus one
and there's three games where I could
have gotten another half point I didn't
have to lose to Leslie I could have
beaten me a minute I could have beaten
sethian and so you could sort of say
that if I was on absolute Tip Top form
and I cashed in all three of those games
I would tie for first but even if you're
on like good form and not amazing form
yeah I still probably wouldn't have time
for first I might have only gotten two
extra half points out of that and
finished on like plus three so it was
not the end of the world but it was a
tough tournament Sam absolutely no shame
in making a draw with the black pieces
against one of the best players in the
world thank you for your games and we'll
see you in your next event which is
literally no idea I have nothing planned
at all
um I wouldn't mind at least a little bit
of a break but you know come December
and January I'd love to get into playing
classical chess again I just don't know
of any events nothing a I don't know if
any I've been invited to but B I don't
know of any at all so you know once
tournaments come you know come at me I'd
love to play but it's uh and I hope I
can play more feisty than I did today
Sam thank you very much Sam a quick
question to you uh was your
determination to play for a win today
motivated by the fact that uh World Cup
uh playoff spots were are up for grabs
yeah I mean certainly in part that was
that was part of it yes uh just also
like I mean I felt like I wanted to get
more points on the scoreboard I mean you
shouldn't lose objectivity based on how
your previous games have gone but also
just with Dominguez like I'm not
I'm not that confident in my ability to
just you know play E5 against him and
just forcefully draw like he's always
able to put pressure and I wanted I just
against him in particular I think the
best strategy is to try to play a
fighting game regardless of whether
you're trying to play for a win with
black on command or not but yeah that
was part of it I just was very very
surprised by Bishop C1 I've literally
never ever seen him make a quick draw
with white once and to that effect you
know I would say look everyone's allowed
one in discretion before you start
condemning them so I'm not gonna give
him a hard time like he if he's
literally never done it once before you
know look everyone gets to do it once
but it was just disappointing to see all
right once again thank you uh very much
uh Sam Shanklin and well our standings
after those two very quick results